at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking so no oil see you're posting a
question now it is CNN
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton well hello boys
and girls ladies and germs my esteemed
and lovely listeners short version I'm
getting rid of ads and sponsors for a
six month test and the podcast will
continue to be free 100% free nothing
behind a paywall and you can learn more
about that and why at tim dot blog
forward slash support that's tim dot
blog for slash support i'd really
appreciate if you listen to this message
in faults not going to be super long so
here is a little bit more thousands of
you fans readers listeners have asked me
over the years how can i thank you i
want to thank you on twitter and all
sorts of other places what can i do to
thank you besides buy your books and
i've never had a product i've never
wanted to just come up with a product or
a course or fill in the blank
nonetheless nearly four hundred episodes
with the podcast later four hundred
million or so downloads a thousand plus
blog posts and so on i've thought about
this and i've thought about it a lot
recently because the sponsorship model
and i actually look at the calendar it's
great on a lot of levels but it cuts
into time and resources i'm not learning
very much and it's an elegant model in
some respects I don't think advertising
or sponsorship is evil and I turn away
90 plus percent of my sponsor inquiries
anyway
test everything reject another 90
percent and only share the stuff I end
up using personally so I don't feel
badly about that at all I feel really
good about it but it chews up a ton of
time and energy for me and my team which
I would rather spend on doing more
experiments doing more crazy pushing the
envelope stuff that I can then report on
and share with you that is in my power
zone and it's why many of you ended up
reading my books are listening to this
podcast in the first place so I'd rather
do more of that sort of less hustle more
art and experiment
so this seems to be that is a fan
supported model the most direct way to
fix this and it's just the cleanest most
attractive way to go about it I want to
simplify simplify simplify do more
experiments do really really cool stuff
like for instance you've seen me support
studies for treatment-resistant
depression at Johns Hopkins and other
places I want to do more of that kind of
thing I want to do all sorts of wacky
things that I can then report back on
and look if we try the fan support model
for six months and it doesn't work then
we go back to sponsors because the
podcast has really become the Machine
the engine that feeds everything else
and I want to have a sort of positive
dent in the world and the fuel for a lot
of that comes from the podcast and what
do you get for that you don't get a beer
koozie I'm not going to mail you a bunch
of garbage that you don't want it's
really if you just feel awesome about
supporting what I want to do in the
world and the experiments I want to
conduct and the learnings I want to
share and so on that's it so if my book
if the podcast if anything has had a
significant impact on you or people you
love in any way just consider giving a
few bucks a month to it and you can find
it at tim dot blog for it slash support
you can finish the entire process in
less than two minutes
tim dot blog for it slash support if it
doesn't feel great to do don't do it you
don't have to pay for it it's always
gonna be free it's never gonna be behind
a paywall
so don't sweat it it should feel awesome
you should feel really good about doing
it if you do it at all and if you don't
don't do it really you're just going to
have an upgraded listener experience for
the next six months without sponsors and
if this experiment fails meaning the fan
support stuff then we'll go back to the
sponsorship model okay check it out
tim dot blog ford slash support and it
would really mean a lot and it'll also
give me an opportunity to see how many
diehards are there how many people out
there would actually
want to support in this way so I'm
really curious tim dot blog forward
slash support thanks for checking it out
love you back to our scheduled
programming
this episode was recorded at the
brand-new first ever and gorgeous
location of made by we we works first on
demand retail location located in new
york city's flat iron neighborhood you
will find all sorts of offerings and
goodies at made by we including
on-demand work and meeting space it is
truly beautiful you should check it out
coffee and artisanal food by blue stone
lane a fully equipped market stand full
of snacks apparel travel and office
products plus curated events evening
programming that's what i was part of
and more so if you want to try out we
work if you want an alternative to
working in your bedroom or at your home
office
aka kitchen table or in coffee shops
this might be the easiest way to dip
your toe in the water you can try it out
by the hour or even by the minute
instead of a monthly or ongoing
membership check it out at made by we
calm and full disclosure I am an advisor
to we work julie rice who's Julie rice
she's an entrepreneur best known for
co-founding the fitness phenomenon
SoulCycle rice served as co CEO at soul
cycle from 2006 to 2015 before joining
we work in November 2017 as a partner
races life's work has been about
building community we work rice is
approaching everything through the lens
of community she's focusing on we works
brand and the experience we work
provides its members and seeking new and
innovative ways to grow and share it the
we work experience around the globe and
a common thread that we're gonna explore
is connection and we're gonna get into
all sorts of details and tactics relate
to that rice lives here in New York City
with her husband Spencer and their two
daughters she is a board member of the
Public Theater and Weight Watchers as
well as an advisor to the Women's Club
the wing you can find her on social
media instagram at julie rice underscore
tricky at your the res underscore and on
linkedin as julie rice
welcome to the show and thank you for
being here thank you for coming to visit
although this is your home so thanks for
having thank you for having visit and
we're gonna jump all over
chronologically which is my my habit I
try to turn that bug into a feature
we'll see how I do and flashback to
childhood so were you a well-behaved
child or do you have any memories of
misbehaving getting in trouble yeah so I
was a super well-behaved child like
borderline nerd actually I was the kid
that didn't have a curfew because I
actually called my parents before it was
time to come home to let them know when
I would be home but I did get in trouble
once in a very big way and I will tell
you what happened I decided I wanted to
get a second piercing in my ear and my
mother said absolutely not I was 11
years old and that was completely
inappropriate to have a second piercing
in your ear and I had one friend she was
my most rebellious friend
her name was Laura and we decided to
take the bus to the White Plains
Galleria Mall and we were gonna get our
ear pierced anyway and so we did we took
the bus and she convinced me that it was
no big deal and my mom wouldn't even see
it so I just came home and put my thing
over my hair and you know my mom
actually didn't notice it and so I told
her you know what I actually think she
noticed it I was actually such a nerd I
told her that you know I couldn't do it
for more than five minutes that telling
her that I got my ear pierced so I I
admitted that I got my ear pierced and
my mom decided that a great punishment
for me well first she called the woman
who pierced my ear to explain that you
actually couldn't you know put holes in
the body of minors without their
parental consent and the woman didn't
seem to really care that my mom thought
that and she said well if you don't like
it then you should sue me so my mom
decided that she would she decided that
she was going to sue her for $8.99 the
entire contents of my piggy bank that I
took to get my ear pierced and that I
was going to have to take the stand yes
and that's exactly what happened with my
which meant my mom went to the library
and she was her own lair and she figured
out that yes in fact you could not
pierce the body of a miner without
parental consent and then I had to go to
court and get up on the stand as the
most terrified eleven-year-old that you
have ever seen to tell them that yes I
had disobeyed my parents I've gone to
the Galleria Mall and gotten a second
piercing mom so what did your parents do
professionally um my dad was a phys ed
teacher and my mom was she had actually
an antique business when people moved
from homes or estates she appraises the
contents and sells them off she's kind
of like an art historian and you said
white plants so where did you grow up I
grew up in Westchester in New York
Westchester all right so we're gonna
flash-forward has promised to a year
before SoulCycle could you paint a
picture for us where are you what's
going on in life yes so I have had this
is just about my third career I started
out my first career was I worked in the
movie business as a kid I have always
been obsessed with theater with musical
theater that was always kind of my thing
I loved entertainment and I always
wanted to figure out a way to work in
the movie business and I remember coming
home you know my sophomore year of
college and saying to my dad who was a
gym teacher and my mom who worked in an
antique business like don't you people
know anybody I need an internship
somewhere this is never gonna happen for
me unless we know somebody and my dad
recalled that he had worked with some
woman whose husband ran a kid's talent
agency cut - I got some internship and
long story short I I did find my way
into the movie business and I worked in
New York for about eight years as a
commercial agent and then I kind of
figured out that if I really wanted to
go to the next place in my life I would
need to go to California and so I went
to LA and I became a manager in Los
Angeles and I did that for about ten
years
and after ten years I kind of flash
forwarded ahead to what people's lives
looked like you know in the
entertainment business servicing clients
all the time kind of you know really
being you know a prisoner to a lifestyle
of servicing people and although I loved
artists which is what I was always in it
for I really thought to myself like I'm
kind of ready to go back to the East
Coast I'm kind of ready to make a change
and I came back to the East Coast and I
my husband and I both went into our
offices on the same day at the time I
met my my husband in Los Angeles he was
an agent at William Morris and I was
working for a management company and we
decided we were going to you know head
off for sort of nobler professions and
head back to the East Coast keep it real
and we got up one morning and we lived
in Malibu at the time it was sort of
like our swan song we decided to move to
Malibu on the beach because we knew we
were gonna head out of the west coast
and we got up one morning and we said
okay today is the day like we're both
gonna go quit our jobs and we're gonna
tell everybody goodbye and like we're
going back to the East Coast and my
husband and I had we left that morning
and he came home and I came home at the
end of the day and we said how'd it go
and he said oh yeah everybody said you
know great job thanks a lot whatever and
you know I'm all I'm all good and I said
oh well
they told me that they were gonna move
my assistant a month ahead of me and
that I should take a month on the road
and that I could do this in New York if
I wanted to and then I started thinking
like how are we gonna pay our rent so I
kept my job so basically the picture was
that I came back to New York and I was
running a New York office for the agency
that I'd worked for in Los Angeles and I
was still working in the movie business
and I was you know really um you know
having a better time doing it here but
definitely beginning to think about kind
of what's next I mean I'd been thinking
about what was next already when I was
thinking about leaving the West Coast
and the one thing that was really going
on for me here in New York was that in
LA you know so much of my life had been
tied up in lifestyle pursuit you know I
went hiking with my friends I belonged
to a running club we lived at the beach
when I came back to New York there was
just nothing here that was lifestyle
fitness was really about going to a big
box gym burning calories having somebody
yell at you about you know were you
beating the person next to you could you
push harder you know how could you you
know get it done quicker and more
efficiently and you know it's
interesting cut to 2006 you know there
was no green juice in this city there
was no boutique fitness there were a
couple of yoga studios but certainly
what's going on today was not what was
going on you know in 2006 in New York
and so for me there was a real void even
though I was desperate to come back to
the East Coast and be with my family
there certainly was a void in what I had
experienced in Los Angeles in terms of
lifestyle so I want to talk about just
for a moment managing talent so what is
what does a manager do and based on what
you just said which what you said
several things but one of which was they
said great we'll give you a bunch of
time off and you can then pick up with
your job you I would imagine we're good
at that job so what does it manage to do
and what were some of your better bets
or better decisions as a manager sure so
a manager you know an agent is
responsible for getting actors jobs and
a publicist is responsible for making
sure that people know about those jobs
and a lawyer is making sure they making
that they don't get screwed over in the
contracts for those jobs I'm kind of
what a manager does is think about big
picture you really think about who that
person is who they want to be in the
world what I learned actually from being
a manager is you're really thinking
about creating a brand for a person you
know what is that person's brand you
know what does it's how do they walk
through the world what do they stand for
you know what do people think about when
you know when they think about an actor
and actress everything from their
fashions the things that they endorse to
you know the way that they talk in
interviews and really thinking in terms
of you know how do I plan a career not
just
job to job for this person and when you
get to LA or got to LA you transition to
this this job as a manager were there
any any particular wins or fines from
the perspective of talent people you
chose to work with or ended up working
with the come they come to mind if you
can talk about them I definitely can
well I will definitely say that I think
that you know one of my sort of better
skills in life is picking people I've
seen that I agree I'm a very good people
picker I think I mean I have I've just
about the greatest husband I chose a
fantastic business partner and I feel
actually very lucky in my life with my
friends and the people that are around
me are all dynamic and really feed me
and you know in in very specific ways
but I've always been a good people
picker and I only love people and what I
really love is I love the nuances that
make people the people that they are and
you know those little things about
people that are special or things that I
feel like I can really see and something
that I love doing in the world is trying
to help figure out how to connect the
world to the things that are special
about those people and so I've had good
luck all along you know early on in my
career I Ellen Pompeo was a bartender
that wouldn't give me a drink and when I
finally gave her my card and her
boyfriend found it in the laundry a
couple months later she called me and we
had quite a good run I worked with selma
Blair for awhile I worked with Justin
long and then when I was in Hollywood I
worked on the teams of people I worked
for a bigger company but I worked on the
teams for people like Jennifer Lopez and
Sean Combs and Will Smith and those were
not necessarily people that I found but
I was actually really lucky to be a part
of those teams because I worked for
somebody a guy named Benny Medina who's
like a very famous talent manager he's
created a lot of incredible artists and
really he was one of the first people
that really thought about how you create
artists into brands he would take
somebody like Jennifer Lopez
and think how can we release an album on
the same day as we release a movie on
the same day as we put a fragrance into
the world and I think that was pretty
early thinking back then in terms of 360
thinking about how you could turn a
person into a company let's let's
flashback to Ellen who mentioned
bartender bartender what did you see
because now as context for me as well as
people who are listening do do the most
successful iconic managers have five
clients 50 clients a hundred clients
what does that tend to look like in
terms of the number of people you work
with and then what did you see in LA
sure so it's when you're starting out
you know it's it's much more you know
you're betting and you're betting on on
more people right so usually in the
beginning you start with about 25 or 30
people you're you know first of all your
ability to sign you know you're not
going you're not you know me at 25 in
the world saying to j.lo like hey come
on with me you know that's not happening
so you know you're you're you're trying
to identify talent you're trying to find
people that you think are going to have
trajectory and you're usually signing
between 20 and 25 of them and then
watching their you know how their
different careers are advancing as your
clients become more successful what
winds up happening is you personally
hand the less people because now you're
really building companies and if things
are going great you're actually
producing things you're looking for
properties for them you know you're
really overseeing pretty much every
decision for them and so you're probably
at that point handling between if
they're mega stars you're having between
one and three
if they're big stars you're having
between three and five you know and if
you have a bunch of people on you know
TV series and other things you know I'm
gonna say that once your once your
clients are successful you don't have
more than ten that you're personally
handling you might have a team of people
below you that are handling a bunch and
you're kind of saying like yes to that
no to that whatever but your hands on
with I'm gonna say between three and
five and what do you see an Ellen what
what made you think and the reason I'm
asking this just for people who are
wondering why is he drilling so deeply
on this is that whether you think of
yourselves as investors or not you're
all in
Esther's in the sense that you are
allocating your hours you're allocating
your attention and so in a way her
choosing clients is putting together an
investment portfolio I mean you're
placing bets and you have finite number
of bets you can place so why why Ellen
what did you would you see you know I
saw in Ellen interestingly enough what I
ultimately wound up looking for in
SoulCycle instructors what I ultimately
look for in employees and what I
actually do ultimately look for in
entrepreneurs which is you know there
was something about her that made me
want to know her that made me want to
understand what she was thinking what
she was going to be doing you know when
I when I when I used to audition
SoulCycle instructors I would say the
main criteria that I had for a SoulCycle
instructor was do I want to have a whole
meal with you you know I'm talking about
an appetizer an entree and dessert and
I'm still not bored of you you know
really you know how do you connect to
people and you know watching her there
was something that was there was
something that was just fascinating
about her there was something that was
really deep that I wanted her to tell me
and I think that's really interesting I
think that you know there are certain
kinds of people that you really want to
lean into and whenever I sort of have
that instinct when my body kind of wants
to lean into somebody to know a little
bit more I genuinely know that that's a
person that I need to sort of surround
myself with because there's something
about that person that is you know
interesting for me so we're back into
SoulCycle land which is perfect
when did soul cycle become something
real in the sense that there was a
concrete action of some type of taking
it from in the head to into the world in
some way right that's what actually you
know
separates the boys from the men right I
always say everybody's got an idea
tucked away somewhere yeah so I was
working in New York I was still working
in the talent business and I was taking
classes at many different gyms just sort
of trying to find something that you
know fulfilled me in terms of exercise
I'm a anxious person exercise is a real
must for me in my life to sort of keep
myself and everybody around me and you
know good spirits and I I just couldn't
find anything that was enjoyable and I
kept thinking to myself like this could
be different this could be fun this
could make you feel good and I was
taking classes with an indoor cycling
instructor at a gym and I became
friendly with her and I just kept saying
all those things to her and finally she
said to me you know there's a woman that
takes some classes with me at another
gym and she's been saying the same thing
to me you guys should meet for lunch and
so she connected me with my business
partner who's right there and my other
my other soul mate as I like to say and
we had lunch one day and it was really
the craziest thing I mean it's a hard
story to believe because we met for
lunch we had a couple our lunch it was
in the winter and it was I was in Soho
house here in New York and we have lunch
and it was crazy it was like we had the
same exact idea and we were just
completing each other sense is and when
I left lunch that day before I even got
in my cab my cell phone rang and it was
Elizabeth and she said to me um you know
I'm gonna look for real estate and you
look at towels and I'll call you on
Thursday and I thought wow like that's
amazing I mean I still had a job and you
know whatever and sure enough like she
called me on Thursday and she said I
found something on Craigslist
she said it's 1,200 square foot sublet
of an old dance studio we could take a
5-year sublet and you should meet me
tomorrow on 72nd Street and I went and
four months later we opened
how are you doing on the towels she like
so how are you doing on the towels so
it's really interesting actually in case
anybody wants to start a business um it
turns out that when you have a 1200
square foot studio and you don't
actually have laundry facilities what
you do is you rent towels and somebody
picks them up and takes them away every
day and launders them and I learned that
on Google and I I dutifully brought my
towel report that day as she was signing
the lease for our Craigslist dance
studio you you based on just the reading
that I've done in preparation for this
made made some in retrospect would seem
to be very important decisions one of
them was deferring or minimizing payment
to yourselves it seems and I read about
maybe you could talk about the I think
it was what these every Sunday the $200
ATM is about that but could you explain
the rationale behind that and could you
elaborate on the the weekly ritual with
the ATM definitely um so when we started
SoulCycle I you know I actually like I
had a good job I was making real money
and you know it was really the first
time actually that I ever thought about
my time as money because I was sort of
giving up a salary now and you know I
was gonna be using all my time but
wasn't gonna necessarily be taking I
took I took a small salary because at
the time that's what we needed to do but
my husband was working luckily and he
was supporting us but we had a five
month old baby and we moved into a rent
control apartment we paid a little less
than $1,000 a month
we lived on 71st Street over Harry's
burritos and I had a five month old baby
who's in the front row she's not such a
baby what are you wearing
[Laughter]
um and yeah so so what we decided was
that we were you know we were gonna make
sacrifices so that we could start this
business and Spencer my husband would go
to the cash machine on Sunday nights and
he would take out $400 we decided that
when we started the business we were
gonna give our credit cards up and we
were gonna put ourselves on like a real
budget which we hadn't really done
before we were two people with no kids
and two salaries and you know we weren't
making tons of money but we certainly
had enough that we could each go to
Starbucks and take cabs and go out for
dinner and not think about a vacation
and so Spencer would give us a white
envelope each of us on Sunday nights we
each got $200 and that was our money for
the week and when the $200 was gone that
was you should boost meaning he got was
he got 200 bucks and I got 200 bucks and
I will tell you with with a child in New
York City $200 does not go that far so
it was like you know a lot of strollers
on the crosstown bus you know not a lot
of Starbucks but that's what we did and
you know it actually you know I think
that one of the really interesting
things about you know really believing
and what you're doing and being so
passionate about an idea and really
believing that something should be born
was it was hard and you know I remember
clamping my finger in that stroller a
million times and cursing on that bus
but it didn't really feel like that big
of a sacrifice I mean we were happy and
we Elizabeth and I were were loving what
we were doing and we did it and you know
we lived and we lived in one room and
you know and we wanted to watch TV we
rolled the crib into our bedroom and we
wanted to go to sleep we rolled the crib
back out into the living room and that's
what we did
and I was thank you for painting a
picture because I think it's and you
already said sort of anxious by by birth
so it doesn't strike me as the perfect
time to necessarily start a company in
end and just with a five-month year old
kid and five-month year old kids
it's not what they say and the it's
sorry guys for the Brits in the audience
that's that's that's American that's
Yanks speak it I think just highlights
the fact that if if you really have
something you want to do and feels
important there's very rarely going to
be a perfect convenient time to do it
you know it was such a gift that had
happened so quickly I about Elizabeth my
business partner sort of being a great
entrepreneur and me being a really hard
worker and I think that's part of what
makes us such great partners
Elizabeth's an incredibly good
risk-taker I always say Elizabeth's like
a total baller and I'm just sort of
running behind trying to work really
hard but the truth is that I think
because she was such a good risk-taker
because she's so good at moving the ball
forward it all happens so quickly I
didn't actually have time to be anxious
or think oh I'm giving up my job and
what's gonna happen it was just like we
met on Tuesday we saw the place on
Thursday we went across the street to
Starbucks we wrote on a napkin which you
know we still have framed it says you
know if we could see a hundred people a
day you know at $27 a bike we're gonna
have enough money to pay for some
babysitter's we both had young kids at
the time we're gonna be able to pay our
studio staff we're gonna be able to take
a little bit out of the business to
justify the fact that we're not raising
our own kids for the next decade and and
that was our business model on the back
of that Starbucks napkin and the truth
is it happened quickly and we just got
into action mode so quick that we didn't
have a lot of time to obsess about what
if what if what if like we just had to
make it happen every day what names what
other names were candidates for the
business besides SoulCycle or was that
just like a lightning bolt from the sky
and that was it did you guys that was a
lightning bolt to Elizabeth's husband in
the shower one day it was not a
lightning bolt to either of us but you
know we thought of you know we thought
of a bunch of different names you know
at the time again there was no boutique
fitness in New York City and so we felt
like we needed something sort of
descriptive about the cycling part of it
in the names we thought about cycle NYC
you know we definitely had a lot of
cycle in the name and the different
other names because we felt we needed to
be somewhat specific for people and then
you land it on SoulCycle how did you
decide on the business model so not just
say the technology and the ambience and
all these other elements that made it
different but how did you dis how did
you both think about developing the the
business model so it's it's interesting
um I think that you know again at the
time the landscape was you know in New
York City there were big box gyms and
the model that was profitable was you
went in you gave somebody your credit
card they took an imprint of it and then
they just hope that you never came
because the best thing that could happen
was that they could double or triple
book your spot when they were figuring
out their utilization and rather than
take four hundred members they could
have eight hundred members or even
better both of those people didn't show
up and they could have twelve hundred
members and so for us you know we we
really we really began to think about it
in a different way and I think a lot of
it you know had to do also with with our
idea that we were tasking ourselves to
create a really special experience every
time you know to the point of being a
theater lover and thinking about things
in terms of a production we used to
always say that every time somebody
crossed the threshold it's SoulCycle it
was curtain up and until they left it
was curtain down because we were only as
good as their last experience when we
decided on a paper class model everybody
thought that we were crazy like why
wouldn't you just take people's credit
cards why wouldn't you discharge them
and for us it was a challenge to
everybody there from the people at the
front desks know your name to the
instructor in that room to deliver a
certain kind of experience to us to make
sure that the brand was delivering a
message and continuing to innovate and
we just really felt like we wanted to
challenge ourselves in that kind of way
we wanted to deliver that kind of
experience every time were there any
other early decisions that proved either
particularly in
portal slash good or particularly bad
there were many decisions that not that
proved but I proved both of those things
let's talk about the good ones first uh
I think that you know when we started
SoulCycle there were there were quite a
few things that even though our business
model on the Starbucks napkin might not
seem sophisticated I think that we were
we were smarter than we thought that we
were and we thought about a few
different things we thought about
technology we thought about the fact
that at the time you had to go to the
gym an hour early to put your name on a
paper list and sign up for a class that
was only going to be 45 minutes long so
your gym experience now turned into two
hours plus for 45 minutes worth of
exercise and so we created the first
online reservation system we thought
about brand a lot we thought about
creating something we never thought
about SoulCycle like we're creating a
gym you know for us or muses were things
like the white cube you know the art the
art gallery in London or an Apple store
we always thought about ourselves in a
much different way and creating a brand
and you know we never compared ourselves
to fitness and we always thought sort of
if we could create a brand if we could
set a stage if we could create a place
where people felt safe and empowered and
like they could share with other people
if we could set that stage and create
that for people then they could have a
different experience and they could have
in an environment that wasn't like that
we also really thought about community
and we thought about you know how do we
create a place where people support each
other you know so much of what was going
on at gyms was competition between
people and for us it was all about you
know some days I'm not gonna feel like
exercising but like if you can bring it
for me on Monday and I can bring it for
you on Wednesday and we can all raise
each other up
what is that kind of a place feel like
because as Co participants corrects it
correct and you know there were a lot of
little decisions that we made along the
way you know and things also that just
happened to us in a lucky way we started
out with 35 bikes in the room we got
popular before we could find a second
space so we ended up with 45 bikes in
the room and
did that do it put the bikes this close
to each other and when people were done
complaining about can you believe
they're gonna charge $27 and I'm gonna
have to sit that close to somebody what
actually happened was the lights were
dark and people could all feel the music
at the same time and he could almost
feel somebody breathing next to you and
your foot was on the same beat as their
foot was on and all of a sudden it
became connected and it became tribal
and it was dark and there were candles
and the music was amazing and an
instructor is telling you that you could
be more than you thought you could be
and somehow the room is moving together
in a way that you you don't often feel
connected to people like that even when
you're having deep conversation there's
something about a moving meditation with
other people that are rooting for you
that are holding space for you that
aren't there to compete with you that
are there to elevate you so that they
can be elevated as well and when we
created an experience like that it was
magic I mean it was really magic and you
know that is kind of was it was a really
transformational thing for people it's
it's really remarkable among other
things that that you two are still close
in the sense that a lot of co-founders a
blow to smithereens at some point like
they get speed wobbles maybe because the
company's going really quickly they
might not have the important
conversations up the front that they
should have there are a million and one
reasons why a lot of these relationships
don't work out I don't know if this
factors in but could you talk to
coaching or advisors and if if and how
you've you've utilized people to help
you guys develop and maintain close
bonds and ability to work together
definitely so early on in our business
life Elizabeth and I started to see a
coach and the way that that happened was
we had a third business partner in the
beginning and that was we quickly found
out that you know that partnership was
not necessarily going to work
and we realized you know as that
partnership was crumbling that it takes
work to make good partnerships something
that I have worked on my marriage
something that you know is no longer a
secret to me that people actually need
skills and tools to be in relationships
with other people you know I there are
plenty of people that are in
relationships that are fine but if you
really want to have great relationships
that's actually a particular skill set
right and so Elizabeth and picture I
don't really know Elizabeth very well at
this point I mean we're about a year
into business you know we met at this
lunch we decided like let's just go for
it I mean you know we're still we're
still pretty much strangers and you know
Elizabeth you know while I was in LA
growing a career Elizabeth's in Colorado
she goes to University of Boulder she
spends her time in Telluride she is like
a much more sort of evolved spiritual
you know at peace with the world person
than I am I'm still like I've only lived
on the coasts you know I've only done
mac rind so Elizabeth calls me in the
middle of the night and she says you
know I've googled life coach NYC I've
realized she's having a nervous
breakdown because she realizes that our
business is taking off our third partner
is walked you know we got to get rid of
our third partner who's completely toxic
and now it's like what's gonna happen
here and we both have little kids at
home and you know the worst thing that's
happening is that our business is
becoming such a success that like we're
gonna have to you know put our foot on
the gas here and so she said she's she's
googled life coach NYC and then I should
meet her tomorrow
at some more some location around
Gramercy because we're going to meet
with the coach and I'm thinking I hang
up the phone I say to my husband like
this woman is batshit crazy like there
is no way like I have to work tomorrow
oh there's no way I'm getting myself in
a cab going all the way downtown to go
to some hotel and sit with some life
coach NYC like I'm thinking we're
sitting with Dionne Warwick and she is
gonna tell us you know but sure enough I
mean we get there and you know we start
to talk to our coach who by the way we
still work with today we I don't there
are so many decisions in my life and our
life
that we wouldn't make without her and I
met with a woman her name is Meredith
Haberfield she has an incredible company
called think human and we started to
talk about you know what it what it's
like to be good partners and you know
what it takes to make decisions together
and like any relationship you know
you're two people that have a common
vision but are in very different moments
in your life at all times and a business
relationship is no different I mean
there are times that like I need money
and you don't or you know I I need to
slow down for a minute because
something's going on in the life of my
family and you want to put your foot on
the gas or whatever and or there's just
things that you want to do with the
business I'm ready to sell the business
and you're not you know how does what
does that all look like and and
everything along the way from learning
how to be the only two employees in a
company to managing twenty five hundred
employees and what do you look like as
leaders and how do you communicate with
your employees and so we started down
this journey with Meredith our therapist
coach life coach NYC I really think
she's changed her her website since then
you know we've we've worked with her for
a long time now ten years and I will I
will say that she taught us lessons that
helped inform the entire way that the
culture of our company would exist you
know we would learn how to have a
conversation with each other and then we
would take those skills and we would
codify them we had an incredible chief
culture officer and we'd work on them
we'd learn had those skills and then
we'd bring her in to learn that skill
and then we'd codify it and we would
teach the entire organization how to
communicate like that and we did that
until we created a really extensive
library of tools that we use to build a
culture and what was amazing was and you
know I know that you speak to so many
founders that have spoken businesses
have started businesses but I really do
believe that you know just like the way
that I was saying to you like the
nuances of people what makes them
special or just just so intricate and so
interesting I really think that the new
on
of great businesses come from the DNA of
their founders you know it's those very
things that make those people special
that ultimately make those companies so
special but the problem is right after
it goes from two employees to 2,000
employees how do you take that DNA and
keep it in a place that's really what it
was meant to be and I will say that
finding that coach was so lucky not only
for me personally I can honestly say
that it is has changed who I am as a
human being and who I ever would have
been able to be as a leader but it also
allowed us to scale this kind of stuff
into our culture which was incredible
for employees I mean we gave them tools
like you know how to get unstuck which
was really just teaching them how to
have a conversation about what was
bothering them and to create spaces
where they could have those
conversations and not feel like people
were gonna judge them or you know reward
them or punish them for what they were
saying you know we had an expression
sort of you know saying no lumpy carpets
we created a you know an ethos where it
was you know you had to communicate with
your coworker if something was bothering
you
and we created a space where you could
have those conversations and we taught
people not only how to express
themselves but also how to listen
okay there's so much tone back that's
let's get let's get into it so the the
tools that you developed or we're able
to learn from your coach are are one set
of questions that I'll get to but let me
start with going from oh my god we're
gonna be talking to a psychic get me out
of here I'm busy you're working with
someone for 10 years were you sold in
the first meeting and if so why what did
she do not do ask not ask exude that
that sold you well here here was what
was so interesting about you know our
meeting I mean first of all it was
definitely one of those lean in moments
you know I had never really met somebody
who had such different life experience
than me and was so different than me and
yet saw it all the same Elizabeth and I
have such completely different things
that we bring to our partnership and
relationship and yet at the end of the
day we have a really common vision and I
think that that's really that that's
really what drew me to her and in the
case of Meredith specifically how did
she overcome your skepticism about that
use of time well first of all she's just
completely cool and normal like if she
was here with us she would just be you
know Brit us you know she's super she's
just she's just and she's just real you
know there's there's no [ __ ] it's
like she will call you on it and she
asks you really hard questions
you know you'll sit there and defend
something for fifteen minutes well
that's not how I see it and that's not
how I want it and the yeah but that's
Citra and then she'll say to you that's
all great here's what I want you to
think about and you don't have to answer
it now she'll say to you something like
this at the end of your life when you
look back on this who do you want to
have been how do you want people to have
thought of you and you'll just go wow
because that's some different [ __ ] than
what I was about to fending right now
wow that's way different than being
right in this room right now you know
when I think back to the end of my life
and I think back about the way that I
want people to have thought of me or
have listened to people or taken a
moment to considered somebody else's
feelings or point of view or put myself
in their shoes I mean that's some
different stuff than being right in the
moment and you know when somebody asks
you a question like that you know you
stop and it's always questions like that
or or it's questions and a lot of times
it's just you and yourself and she'll
just ask you questions like you know
about why you're doing things you know
is it about your ego is it about the way
other people think about you is it
because you need more money you know
questions that you
I don't know I have not done enough work
on myself to ask to really ask myself
those questions I'm really good still at
talking myself into the things that I
want to hear when you were talking about
the getting unstuck if I'm getting that
right or and no lumpy carpets or no
lumps in the carpet I might begin the
phrasing wrong or managing these what
could be very uncomfortable
conversations with a partner about
wanting to sell when someone else
doesn't want to sell it whatever the
conversation might be it seems like a
lot of those tools and whether it's for
employees or for the two of you is about
having uncomfortable conversations
successfully and the managing conflict
are there any specific recommendations
tools anything at all or examples you
could give of how to approach say the
the employee who has something that is
bothering them about a co-worker and
kind of walking them through how to do
that in a way that doesn't lead to World
War three well you know first of all I
think that you know for better or for
worse I think that you know company
culture also has a lot to do with it I
think that creating environments where
it's safe for people to do those things
you know there's so there's so much
politicking and you know things that
still go on in many places where you
know that sort of you know you have to
actually reward that behavior you know I
do think that that is something that is
you know it has to be considered but
what I will say is that you know I do
think that having those conversations
and beginning to have those
conversations really start with teaching
people how to listen first you know I
think that training people how to to
listen to what somebody else has to say
um allows people who then have issues to
go and be heard I will tell you about
something actually great that my husband
and I have done for a long time which
actually changed the dynamic of our
relationship and I can honestly say that
it's you know if I if I had to say sort
of the other best thing that I've ever
done is um you know we had our first
daughter and all of a sudden we were no
longer two people that could just do
what they wanted whenever they wanted
you know if we both wanted to go to take
different exercise classes at different
gyms at the same time well somebody had
to stay home with our kid and that began
to create conflict you know we no longer
had the time that we used to have to
ourselves we no longer had the autonomy
it's you know it's different you know
when you're when you have a child and so
you know we had we'd started arguing and
we had started um
you know having all this conflict and my
husband who happens to be a much more
evolved person than I am in a much
better communicator um said you know
well maybe you should go talk to
somebody and we started to go to some
couples counseling and see different
marital people you know on a hunt for
some solution to this and you know when
we were in the room with couples
counselors and therapists you know we
would basically were to like really
smart people so we would just play the
win the therapist game you know so we'd
spent a couple hundred bucks an hour
trying to figure out who was gonna
actually win that day and then finally
you know we quit the couples therapy and
because I pissed liked him better and
and then finally you know Spencer was
seen a therapist on his own and she said
she had given him a suggestion and she
said you know you should read this book
and it's called getting the love that
you want and he brought it home one day
and he started to read it and he would
say to me like you've got to read this
this book is really amazing and before
he was through the book he had gone out
and bought a copy for me and said like
we should read this together and so we
started to read this book and before we
were done with the book we had actually
signed up for the workshop and I bring
this up because this is actually a
technique that we have learned that you
can use with your employee
you can use with your children you can
kind of use with anybody but we went to
this workshop it was probably the most
important 40 hours of our of our
marriage up until that point and it is
these two older therapists called
Harville Hendricks and Helen Hunt and
here's what's so fascinating
they Harville was the first person to
win Oprah Daytime Emmy he's this amazing
older therapist who had studied
relationships for a long time and was
becoming very prominent and his wife was
also a research professor that was
studying relationships in the brain and
she's she's learning all these things
about the brain and cortisol levels and
he's winning Daytime Emmys and they're
both on their second marriages and
they're actually about to get divorced
while they're all winning all these
awards and stuff and you go and take the
seminar and cut to this 50% of first
marriages end up in divorce
70% of second marriages end up in
divorce and about 90% of third marriages
do teaching you that it has not much to
do with the partner that you choose but
mostly the skill set that you bring to
the relationship right and so here's the
crazy thing
you know nobody teaches us how to be
married nobody teaches us how to
communicate with a partner nobody
teaches us how to communicate with
anybody you know I don't remember being
in a class in school where somebody said
to me you know this is how you listen
this is how you talk to somebody this is
how you consider what they're saying and
really all you do in this workshop is
you learn active listening you know we
learned how to to make appointments with
each other to have conversations that
you're not bombarding somebody at a time
where they can't hear you when you make
an appointment and you say it's your
turn to talk basically you know I say
you know I say what I need to say and
then all that person gets to do is
repeat back to you and say is there more
that's it that's all the person gets to
do a menu with you know what there
always is more really just about that is
it right and then you say what more
there is and then they get to repeat it
back and then they get to say is there
more and you know what happens at the
end of three is there more
rather than trying to win the therapist
and rather than trying to be right what
you realize is that somebody is
suffering about something and that it's
coming from a source of pain not coming
from a source of like at you and it's
not about you being right it's about
taking care of somebody that you love or
taking care of somebody that you work
with or hearing a child that's coming
home from a school that didn't have a
good day or got a bad grade that's
feeling disappointed also and I think
really um you know teaching people how
to listen and how to have conversations
is something that's so important
thank you very specific are there other
examples of ways you've brought things
from that workshop or book or elsewhere
into your relationships aside from the
these specific examples you just gave in
terms of active listening are there any
other tools or habits that you've
adopted or found useful there are
actually many others um I think that one
is really the one that it's it's really
the focus of the workshop and what you
do you know more most often but there
are a lot of amazing practices you know
telling people what's great about them I
mean how often do you you know do you
think about something that's wonderful
about your partner and make sure that
you share that every day how often do
you make time to be proactive about
doing something nice again whether it's
for a spouse whether it's for a child
whether it's for a colleague I think
there are a lot of incredible things
that happen out of that workshop but I
but I will say that you know the
foundation of it is really learning to
listen so you have in you mentioned that
I think and I'm paraphrasing here so
correct me if I'm wrong here but the UC
founders with certain DNA certain
superpowers and that sort of infuses and
informs the organization and I think
it's at least been my experience
observing and being involved with a lot
of companies that also if there is acute
dysfunction in a founder that that can
also sort of infuse its way into a
company so I'm mentioning
just to say that the culture which we
take to be like a shared set of beliefs
and behavior so it says how I think of
it does not just take care of itself
and part of that is doing the work that
that you guys have done as founders both
separately and together are there any
other whether it's books seminars
advisers anything that come to mind is
having made a real difference whether
it's in your business life or in your
personal life that you're like you know
what I would recommend I've tried a lot
of things here a few things I would
definitely recommend that people check
out yeah I mean uh a big a big book at
SoulCycle for us was always start with
why from simon Sinek and I know that
that's made it to a lot of your lists
and a lot of people are simon Sinek fans
but but I will say and you know this is
what I think is so interesting you know
as somebody who is fascinated with brand
and you know the articulation of brand
and all things brand I think that people
are often confused and think of brand as
the way something looks or the colour of
a logo but you know brands are really
how people feel they're really you know
I think it was maybe Jeff Bezos who said
it's what people say about you when
you're not in the room or you know that
kind of a thing and I do think that you
know start with why is so important
because people understanding you know
why you do something not what you are
doing is really what what makes or
breaks a brand and I think everything
about that book is fantastic I think
that you know for us really we we spent
so much time you know I remember the day
that we just really officially stopped
doing our day jobs I looked at Elizabeth
and said like are we ever gonna get to
go back to work or do we have to spend
our whole life making these people happy
you know referring to our employees and
that was the truth but there was a day
where you know it all turned and you
began to realize that if the culture
wasn't gonna be good that the product
wasn't going to be good and I think
that's like a real you know core value
from simon Sinek who really says that
your happiest customer is only as happy
as your happiest
employee and so for us like really
making sure that our employees were
taken care of and and taken care of
meaning you know not just financially
but really felt like they mattered like
the things that they were doing we're
moving the needle for the company that
we personally understood you know things
that they were going through
achievements that that they were you
know making happen I think that really
taking care of employees in a way that
they feel heard is very important what
we're little things or big things that
you did to foster those things to make
this things happen so I mean
interestingly enough one of one of the
main things that we recognized in the
beginning when we started SoulCycle was
that the fitness industry in general was
really broken instructors didn't have
full-time jobs anywhere so if you were a
fitness professional you would teach two
classes at one gym and three classes at
another gym and personal trained
somebody in their home so you'd spend
your entire life sort of you know
commuting and being exhausted just to
try to cobble together a living and then
on top of it for doing one of the most
physical jobs in the world you had no
health insurance
you had no paid vacation and you know
you certainly had no place to call home
or really feel like you had somebody or
to support you or that cared about you
and one thing that was very early on a
goal for us was to create these careers
for fitness instructors which is
something that we really did and you
know we you know we paid more we gave
people full health benefits we paid for
those vacations and you know most
importantly we really gave them a home
you know we built a platform you know
SoulCycle was really a platform that we
built to allow you know we really
thought of you know our fitness
instructors as artists for allow artists
to really find their voice on a platform
and to sort of give them the room to be
creative and to grow into being their
best selves and I think by giving people
that kind of a platform and room and
then really taking care of them and
and of the tactical aspects of their
lives it allowed people to become a
different kind of employee I mean what
we found was that we didn't have
employees what we had was brand
ambassadors you know we had people
walking around so proud that they worked
at SoulCycle telling everybody how
fantastic it was you know it became way
more like a family than it did a job so
I'm gonna ask some questions about good
strategic decisions then we're
definitely gonna get to you see how I
have avoided the failure yes yes no
we're gonna get to the the wastes of
time and money because there are plenty
of those stories in all businesses
initiatives that didn't go quite as
hoped but one story that I read was
related to opening the Bridgehampton
location and how you sort of resisted
the urge to pay yourselves or pay
yourselves much and as I understand also
had not taken outside investment because
I would imagine especially being in New
York City as soon as something seems to
be going really well it's spreading
quite widely that you start getting
calls you start getting emails about
outside investment so could you talk to
why or how you decided when to take
outside investment which could just be
why you didn't take it up to this point
and then the the the thinking behind the
Bridgehampton location which for people
who everybody in this room or a lot of
people I'm sure know where Bridgehampton
is but for those be bought in the wider
world so you have Manhattan and then you
have Long Island and you go way out and
you have this place called the Hamptons
and depending on who you are there's
very little in the middle either you
love or you hate the Hamptons I happen
to grow up as a townie out there so I
have like this incredible inner conflict
and I and I bounce back and forth
between the two and just for people who
do not know so the Hamptons are kind of
the where many of these successful
people from Manhattan go to summer
beautiful beaches where for some people
they go to be seen why why Bridgehampton
how do you guys think about it and why
no outside investment well let me just
say that
you know again to the point of ignorance
is bliss we opened in four months you
know when I look back now and when I
think about all the investing that we've
done and when I think about how the
world is spinning with people raising
money I really think that it was an
incredible luxury to have no investors I
mean we were really allowed to make
decisions that were just the best for
the business we always just used our gut
instincts and you know there was no
choice except doing what was right for
our customers what was right for
employees and really what was right for
SoulCycle I mean we invented a brand
that was like a human being
you know and we would always make
choices if it's you know we have four
daughters and between us but you know
SoulCycle was like our fifth daughter
and we would always you know really make
choices thinking about you know what is
the right choice for this business and
not having money in the beginning I also
think really informed the way that we
market it you know we had no marketing
dollars I mean zero up until ten years
into the business we didn't spend you
know any money on advertising and I
think what it really did was it really
forced us to be incredibly disciplined
and incredibly scrappy and really be a
part of the communities that we were
trying to create you know we would be
out there you know at the mouth of
Central Park handing out flyers and the
in the bike loop I'd be pushing my
stroller up and down Broadway trying to
get doormen to let me into mailroom
buildings so that I could leave flyers
you know if you could actually find our
studio which by the way was in the rear
lobby of a building with no sign on the
outside of it we forgot to talk about
that we'll get through that and the epic
failures but you know we would we were
so happy to see you that we would do
anything I mean I would watch your dog
ID feature parking meter I'd let your
kids sit there and you know you know
play a video game like it didn't matter
like we needed you to like your
experience because we had zero money for
marketing and at the time trying to
convince somebody to come to the back
lobby of an office building actually
that once was a mortuary
to to do that to convince you to pay $27
to click into a bike to be in a darkroom
for 45 minutes I mean if we could get
you there like you had come it was
nothing we weren't doing to get you to
come back but all that being said it
really was interesting because you know
when I think about the way that we
thought about that first studio and I
think about that napkin that we wrote
our hundred riders on you know I think
about starting a business and I think
about this for a lot of young
entrepreneurs and there is so much
low-hanging fruit in the beginning I
mean we really thought about building
that first studio rider by rider and you
know people will say to me
did you everything SoulCycle was gonna
be such a big deal did you ever think
this was gonna happen and what I always
thought to myself was I just knew that I
needed to get a hundred people there and
that was not gonna be a problem for me
because if I had to go and walk up and
down the streets of Manhattan and call
all my friends and get people on those
bikes like a hundred people are coming
today and that was what I thought about
it and I think that that really forced
us to have a different kind of
discipline than if we had had crazy
investment and marketing dollars and um
you know it just it just shaped who we
were in the way that we understood our
customer because we were in it in a
different kind of way and there was a
lot of freedom to that and the great
news for us was that you know our
business model was great I mean we kept
throwing more and more bikes in that
room and it was teeny little place I
mean 1,200 square feet we ended up we
had 40 something bikes in there $27 a
bike going eight times a day you know we
were able to sort of create our first
you know four or five six Studios you
know taking from Peter giving to Paul
selling to Mary you know it was like it
was pretty great I mean we were really
able to finance one with the other and
because we were not taking money out of
the business because we really were that
disciplined we were taking everything
that we made and we were putting it back
into the business and we were growing
organically and again to the same point
of not noticing the Starbucks was
missing from my life and taking the
taxis we were having a great time and it
really didn't feel like we were
suffering so I'm gonna I'm gonna end
there I may be kind of chasing chasing
the wrong trail in terms of
Bridgehampton but so we can snow know we
can scrap it
maybe but I want to highlight something
that's really important that's come up
numerous times with founders of
companies that have done extremely well
on a large scale is that in most cases
especially if the business models
actually work I mean there are some
companies they get very big what this is
about still work but in the case of
something like SoulCycle it it's very
tempting to want to say that you're
aiming for this billion dollar two
billion dollar x billion dollar outcome
but you know as seth godin ascend on the
podcast before it's very easy to hide
when you have this grandiose somewhat
abstract gigantic goal and so he's like
start small because then you have
nowhere to hide if it's like a hundred
people it's a very clear measurable
outcome and with no marketing dollars is
also a common thread that I see with a
lot of these companies that are at least
those I've been exposed to there that
are kind of consumer facing is if you
don't have much in terms of marketing
dollars or you can strain it
deliberately you have to make sure your
product is great like you really have to
ensure that your product or service is
really really good and then your
customers become your marketing well
that's that's that was always the
philosophy right I mean we always knew
and again this was part of it all kind
of all work together right because we
created a paper class model it had to be
great every time or else nobody had to
come back and what we used to say was
like it can't just be good like this
cannot be a utility like this needs to
be so good that people are talking about
it when they're out with their friends
on Saturday night for dinner and they
are wanting you know you want the credit
for finding the coolest greatest thing
that's gonna make your friend feel the
best and you're gonna bring that person
and so the saying in the halls of
SoulCycle would be like we do not create
users we creative Angeles you know and
our evangelists were spreading the
gospel for us and that's really was our
marketing but I will answer your
question about Bridgehampton we were we
were doing very well
and we had become this little Upper West
Side destination and the studio was
bustling and we were selling our classes
really well and we realized pretty soon
everybody was gonna leave for the summer
because that's what happens in New York
right there's a mass exodus to different
beaches and whether you know people are
going to the Hamptons or at the Jersey
Shore or wherever they're going there's
nobody you know here on the weekends in
the summer and so I called Hamptons
magazine to see what it would be to take
you know an ad I thought oh we'll just
take an ad in the 4th of July
you know publication and they gave me
like a staggering quote and I thought
well we certainly don't have that much
money and the truth is you know what we
did was experiential you know I could
sit here and tell you how awesome it is
to be on a bike and what it feels like
and the music and the sweat and the
instructors and the people and then
you're sort of like hmm you still can't
really feel it because you know there's
no music playing and we're not in the
dark and what I found was the only real
way to get people to come and to really
experience it was to come and get them
to take a class and so we comp a lot of
classes we'd tell people if they didn't
like it they should pay that they didn't
like it give them their money back but I
realized that doing something
experiential would be better than taking
an ad and we got a phone call one day
and somebody said there's this great old
potato barn and there used to be some
pole dancing class in there and the pole
dancing class was apparently going out
of business and now the space would be
vacant if we wanted to create a cycling
studio and so we figured you know we
could either spend seventy five thousand
dollars running a quarter page ad in
Hamptons magazine or we could just run
the studio and plan on making no money
and just think of it as marketing
experiment I mean that's all we thought
it was gonna be was marketing dollars
and so we did and we you know we we went
and we we painted the barn and we we
rolled our bikes in there and we put a
big yellow wheel on the wall and we
flung open our doors and the barn became
like a sensation it really became you
know I you know we live in a little bit
of a SoulCycle bubble but it really is
like I mean it's really the epicenter of
you know Hamptons social life you know
people will tell you that you know if
they can go and you know take a class at
the barn it's SoulCycle in the morning
and then sort of you know huh you know
hobnob in between classes they barely
need to go out at night
because that barn sees hundreds and
hundreds of people between the hours of
7 and 12 on a Saturday morning and it
really it what it did for us was it took
our little upper west side business from
being a local kind of great neighborhood
business hundred people a day - all of a
sudden becoming this sort of buzz worthy
New York City on page six in the New
York Times you know destination and we
came back from that summer and what
happened on Mondays at noon which is
when our reservation system opens so if
you want to reserve a bike at SoulCycle
you go on Monday at noon if you have a
specific thing that you'd like to
reserve and you can sign up for your
classes for the full week and what
happened for us when we came back that
that fall was that we started to crash
servers at noon on Monday the the demand
load became crazy and all of a sudden we
noticed like a line of town cars up and
down the street will always be parked
outside for SoulCycle classes there was
no Oberer yet at the time and what it
was is that people were coming from all
over now you know tweeting and their
drivers or whoever whatever rides they
were taken up there would be waiting
outside and it became you know that's
when we knew like we needed to grow the
market doesn't want us to grow you know
it's 2007 and everybody wants a chase
bank or a Duane Reade in their space you
know two women with a business that is
throwing off a bunch of cash still does
not look that attractive okay so how do
you how do you solve that problem well
then 2008 happens you know it still was
not easy but 2008 happened and it
definitely became you know easier for us
to think about getting space after we
you know we started to well we okay so
now let's talk about you know when we
actually did take money because there
did come a point after about you know
four years where we we took money we had
eight studios
and it's interesting our decision to
take money was not so much about the
money itself but again we really loved
what we were doing we could really see
how SoulCycle was changing neighborhoods
and it was changing communities and it
was changing the way that people felt
about themselves and about other people
and we wanted to win you know we had a
first mover advantage and we were
starting to see copycats come into the
landscape and we were introduced to
Equinox um Harvey Spivak who's the CEO
of Equinox and we started to get to know
him and you know the money and the cash
infusion seemed nice although you know
we had a pretty good business I mean the
businesses were making money and and we
could have expanded in the slower way
but we thought to ourselves that you
know we would take a strategic partner
rather than just taking money and they
would be able to help us you know grow
30 studio 15 15 20 30 studios at a time
rather than let's say five or six or
seven a year what were some of the
decisions or initiatives or anything
where you look back and you're like wow
that was a bad use of time or money is
any anything come to mind they're just
or just yeah we should have thought
about that differently well there are
definitely a few I mean we definitely
made a lot of mistakes along the way
neither of us had ever been
entrepreneurs before and there were
small mistakes and there were definitely
bigger mistakes you know Elizabeth
always likes to say you know every time
we would make a mistake it would be
$50,000 we didn't have and she would say
well look at it this way you know
neither of us went to business school
it's like part of our tuition for our
MBAs and that that would that was always
true but you know we started out in our
first studio and what did we know we
didn't never built anything before and
we we built a studio and some guy told
us that he was really good at sound
proofing things and he'd done some porn
studios in Midtown and so we thought
great like this guy's done porn Studios
go to it and he stuffs an insulation
into the ceilings and closed him off and
then you know cut the opening day we
turn on the stereo to find like a line
of irate neighbors outside of our door
and we certainly did not have money to
resound proof the studio and so that was
you know that was really interesting
sure was interesting
fade to black so what would you do well
now we're getting you know I find that
if you can befriend you know local
neighborhood law enforcers sometimes
they will soundproof they will come and
do the sound checks for your studio
later in the evening when there may or
may not be actual classes going on uh uh
and then you might actually be able to
make the sound a little bit lower than
you do during regular classes sometimes
yeah that worked for us for a while
until we had money to resound through
the studio yeah well you have to
sometimes have to build the bridges
you're crossing it yes we built some of
those another fantastic memory was our
first customer appreciation day this one
this is really like one of my favorite I
can talk about studying human behavior
so we decided after about a year we
really wanted to thank the people that
had helped us build business and so what
we were going to do was an entire day of
free classes on Saturday starting you
know seven o'clock in the morning all
day long we were so excited about it I
mean for us giving up a Saturday of
revenue was huge
I mean Saturday was our biggest day we
had four of those a month I mean we were
still living but you know skin of our
teeth we were still going you know so we
we decided we were gonna let everybody
just call the studio rather than use the
reservation system and sign up for free
we were gonna do you know big bowls our
food and free drinks and do sponsorships
and all this great stuff cut to we like
open up the phone lines and of course a
million people that don't ever come to
SoulCycle sign up for the free classes
and now all of our regulars are irate
because they actually don't give a [ __ ]
if they have to pay for class they just
want to be on the bike they want to be
on with the instructor at the time that
they want to be on and now what we have
is hundreds of pissed-off customers who
cannot get into a Saturday class at
SoulCycle and hundreds of people that
may or may not actually show up but just
signed up for
class because I put it in timeout and
that was our first customer appreciation
day so that was a great learning
exercise I would say the worst amount of
money we ever spent was you know scrappy
entrepreneurs no funding
Elizabeth worked on all of our
technology with a web developer in Long
Island
you know they built everything you know
as it came up so you know first we built
it for one studio and then we built it
for 10 studios and then we wanted to
have EECOM and you know until we built
this thing that was basically like
building a million extensions onto a
foundation of a house that couldn't
handle it and so we needed to rebuild
our website and so we were psyched I
mean we had a million dollars to spend
and we were gonna hire the pros and
that's what we did we went out and we
hired a big fancy agency and we worked
on you know articulating our vision and
our brand and we spent six months
explaining to somebody else what we
already knew which was you know our
brand and our experience and the user
experience and things that were kind of
already working on that website and then
was gonna be the big reveal or big fancy
new website and I don't know I mean they
gave us a new you know a new CTO that
was checking all the hardware and
software and all the things that we were
launching but somehow we flipped on the
switch that day and flipped off the
other website and it was great because
eight people could book the same bike in
the same class at the same time and that
was a disaster and then to make it even
better
nobody could fix it one week of signups
went by four weeks of signups went by
six weeks of sign if somebody talked
about using up your goodwill you know
the first few weeks people gave us the
benefit of the doubt we had great
customer service teams people showed up
they gave people hugs they gave people
free classes get up with the hugs yeah
it was like bye bye week number four
people were just like we were just they
just thought we were totally in a blow
and that's actually how our app was born
to divert people from our fancy new
website that never actually got working
I mean it works now but it took us quite
a while I mean we were able to build an
app better than we were able to fix that
that sounds really stressful it was
stressful so I I don't know if if this
is still a thing and maybe it was never
thing and it's just something somebody
wrote on the internet 16 seconds to calm
that's how long I can meditate yeah okay
could you talk about any other any other
that and any other tools that might help
when you're going through an experience
like that so um I'm not really good at
sitting still that's not my specialty
I've definitely tried meditation in many
different forms with many very talented
people and and many trusted friends have
referred me to many places that I I'm
sure are the right places to be
meditating and I have never found it yet
in my being to meditate I think that's
why SoulCycle continues to be such a
huge part of my life just because there
is something in that room for me that is
really meditative and to the point of
coping skills it's still something
that's in my you know daily practice
almost you know at least a couple times
a week but for me I have a friend who
started a meditation studio in Los
Angeles and sent me um you know a
million ways to get onto her app and her
stuff and there is one meditation that I
have found that it's called sixteen
seconds to come and at sixteen seconds
and you basically take one breath in and
one breath out but this guy tells you
why you're interrupting patterns while
you do that because you're focusing on
your breath and he claims that in your
in those 16 seconds you have interrupted
your thought patterns enough that you
have broken the cycle of anxiety and I
choose to believe it the size of 16
seconds and aside from soul cycle are
there other tools habits routines
anything at all that you found to help
you to operate in a high level when
there's the potential to be overwhelmed
by stress I mean you you like you said
you know you don't strike me as the type
to sit still for very long
seemed to do a lot and and get a lot
done and therein lies the risk of I
think overwhelmed so what what are other
things you do to avoid buckling under
overwhelming I will honestly say that
the the number one thing that keeps me
from buckling under is that I have a
really awesome marriage I know that that
sounds funny or or maybe not but I have
chosen a partner who actually is really
amazing at communicating with me during
times and anxiety and actually has sort
of created an atmosphere in our home
that is not super tolerant of my anxiety
in the best way possible so what does
that look like um it looks like it looks
like you know when I walk through the
threshold of my house you know I have a
partner that if I'm stressed out sort of
demands me to communicate about it and
sort of get rid of it and you know we
have a lot of respect for each other and
he usually finds a way to to figure out
what it is that can can bring me down
from that and I will say that being in a
relationship like that with somebody who
is not an anxious person who is able to
kind of deescalate your own anxiety is
is kind of fantastic could you give an
example you don't have to but if you can
of language is so important here right
like the devil's really in the details
so what might he say or ask when he's
like a Code Red
I see what's coming and wants to get you
to talk about it or deescalate what
might be like just this morning we were
preparing for this interview here and I
said to him like are you gonna help me
with the questions for Tim and he said
to me you know I didn't want to say this
to you yesterday but you said that to me
the same way yesterday and you were
asking it to me in a way that obviously
you're very
yes and you know of course I want to
help you but would you like to ask that
in a different way I thought to myself
you know I know he wants to help me
because he is like the biggest supporter
of my whole entire life and I'm sure
that he and I know that he spent a lot
of time thinking about this because he
sent me emails you know that I asked him
to think about this and then I thought
for a second about my own anxiety and
where I was going with it because I
thought you know oh I have something
else to do at 11 and is he gonna help me
at 10:30 and it was my own crazy person
in there thinking like you need to help
me right now that was like my own person
but he does not get worked up like that
and so he said to me like do you want to
ask me differently because you asked me
the same way yesterday and I don't think
and the thing was that was just in my
own check and most of the times that I
you know am communicating badly with him
with my children it's because I'm in a
state of anxiety or distress and I think
having somebody like that by your side
that can check you like that again in a
way that's loving not in a way that's
you know like that I think that really
helps to to bring the situation down and
and I will tell you one other amazing
thing that we do in our house that has
really helped to kind of reframe the way
that we we live so we started to
celebrate Shabbat about five years ago I
was out one day with a friend of mine
who is like a super successful music
executive she's like definitely one of
my main girl crushes you know she's like
a total boss and a real power broker and
we were having a business lunch one day
and at the end of the lunch she said to
me you know I have to duck out a few
minutes early I have to go pick up a
challah for Shabbat a challah for people
who don't celebrate Shabbat is the
braided bread that we eat on Shabbat
right
and um you know one thing that you know
my business partner Elizabeth loves she
always says to me it's always fun to
find out something new that you don't
know about somebody that you think you
know really well so I looked at my
friend Julie and I said really I said
you like celebrate Shabbat on Friday
night and she said yeah you know I'm out
a couple nights of the week listening to
music and I find that you know because
I'm so busy it's really it's a lot of
integrity for our family you know we all
have to be at the dinner table at 6:30
on Friday night and we put our phones
away and we light candles and we don't
take out our phone so the next morning
and it's the one thing that we do in our
house that really you know reframes our
time together and I thought well she's
clearly more important than I am and she
makes this happen so like I could
definitely fit Shabbat in and we started
to have Shabbat and here's the
interesting thing you know we're not
religious people I would say that we are
we're spiritual just in the way that we
believe that you know the way that you
are in the world is the way that you
feel in the world and I think that we
believe in something bigger and that
we're all connected in some way but I
wouldn't say that we're religious but we
started to have Shabbat and we have very
few requirements of our children but one
requirement is that everybody is home
for that evening our daughter who was
five months old when we started
SoulCycle she's now 13 and our rule for
her she can have as many friends as she
wants but she has to be there
and we light our candles at 6:30 and
there's something about the time that it
takes those candles to burn that for me
who cannot meditate being with people
that I love and there's always plenty of
people at our table it's friends or
family and it's always fantastic and
there is just something about the time
that it takes those candles to burn and
not having phones and having a different
kind of conversation with each other and
just it's almost like I've given myself
permission for the evening to shut down
and whatever that is inside of me that
has whenever the minute we light the
candle says like it's cool till tomorrow
the world's gonna wait for you there's
something about that ritual for me
that's really one of the times that I
look forward to most in the week what
what rules do you have
during Shabbat and and does it is it
primarily and what's the duration is
primarily from that dinner to the
following morning and you guys all put
phones away is that the is that the most
important rule are there other rules so
you guys follow no we say you know we
say we like handles and we do say two
prayers in Hebrew it's it's what we do
my husband has recently started playing
the guitar and he's mastering some
guitar songs and so we usually we try to
have some music he's getting pretty good
our kids are usually super embarrassed
if they are friends over there dad's
playing the guitar there mom singing and
clapping so it's a really big hit I
tried to buy a lot of really good
desserts you know everything from levain
bakery to baked by Melissa on down to
lure my kids aren't to stick around the
table for a certain amount of time
Spencer and I try to keep our phones in
the drawer until the following morning
my daughter you know would obviously die
without getting back on snapchat by
about nine o'clock so we allow her to do
that and there are no rules really and
the crazy thing is you know it's just
again it's it's always intimate it
always feels like a safe space it always
feels like people can share like what
really happened to them that week you
know how they're really feeling about
themselves their triumphs their tragedy
is it just feels like there's like no
[ __ ] at the table you know people
are really for all the times during the
week that you had to go out and pretend
it was great or that you were killing it
at work or that I loved you at school
today or whatever it is it just feels
like it's a really kind of you know we
all go you know we go in pajamas or
sweatpants you know no matter who's
coming over and it's just a super
relaxed kind of just bring your best
self or bring your real self I love it
what a beautiful ritual where should I
go from here well you mentioned the
prepping for the interview and the
anxiety were there any questions that
you hoped I would ask you like you know
I have a really good answer to that I
have a really good answer to this type
of question I hope he asked me this or
conversely was there anything we're like
I hope to god he really doesn't ask me
[Music]
this is a bit of a trick or is it well I
have to say you know I did do some
research well I was uh you know getting
ready for the interview and I was really
you know I listened to a lot of very
impressive people on your podcast and I
was really thinking to myself like I
haven't written a book I don't really
have a method for anything so I was
really hoping that you wouldn't ask me
for some sort of dissertation on
something you know I was thinking a lot
a couple of things that I was thinking
about were just you know I was thinking
about SoulCycle a little bit and I was
thinking kind of about what made the
experience special and I was thinking
about if we would talk about that a
little bit just sort of about you know
the construction of what that experience
is like in the room and I think that's
kind of an interesting one you know I
think that we've really crafted the
experience in that room to be a lot of
the things that I think people really
need today and what we've done is we've
really taken you know we've created an
eight-week training program for our
instructors and what we teach in those
three things is we teach them you know
we teach them how to be spiritual and
emotional leaders we teach them how to
be physical fitness instructors so they
can give people what they need for their
bodies and we also teach them how to be
DJs and how to create music like artists
and what I think is really interesting
about taking those three different
tracks of you know psychology you know
physical experience and also creativity
and putting them together is you really
provide something for people in a room
that allows them to access many
different parts of themselves that I
think people don't often get to access
and I do think that there is something
about that and about creating sort of
that moment you know we we've we've
created the class sort of in five stages
I mean there's almost five stages that
we break it down into which is you know
we warm people up you know we pop the
party we break them down we give them a
soulful moment
I'm home like heroes you know and
there's something about that emotional
arc and that physical arc with music
matching at all that I think really
provides people with a lot of what they
need to get today in the world and I
think it's also a really interesting
journey for people to go through
together because although people aren't
speaking and aren't communicating they
are all experiencing a journey together
and so there is it's it's a really
interesting way in a world where people
have almost forgotten how to communicate
with each other because of phones and
digital isolation to allow people to
participate in something where they
really do feel closer and connected to
each other at the end I'd love to ask a
bit more about the spiritual emotional
leaders part what is the what does the
curriculum look like for that you know
there are quite a few there's there's
there several parts of it and I think
the main part of it is allowing people
to have a place to be vulnerable to come
and express their own vulnerabilities as
well as to talk about things that are
that they're thinking about their own
vulnerabilities and then to empower
people to really deliver messages to
people that allow them to you know as
they are wearing down physically as the
music is playing as they are this close
to somebody else who's moving with them
we are teaching them to deliver messages
that allow people to believe that
they're enough that they can be more
than they thought that they can be that
they could achieve more than they
thought that they could achieve that you
know people are rooting for them that
are hoping for them and I think that
there is something about the empowerment
that people get in that room when they
are you know inhabiting their physical
bodies in a way that feels strong and
teaching those you know instructors to
deliver messages of positivity you know
- really they read they read a lot of
you know different sure so many of the
books that are on your list or books
that we are giving them in those classes
and what are some of them
you know the curriculum is actually wide
and that's the other thing also because
we've created it to look more like a
framework and we also like to use the
expression sort of freedom within
framework so we are allowing people to
you know to although they're creating
within that framework to really you know
find their own voice to find their own
music and that's also why I think that
our riders gravitate to different
instructors because somebody that's
moving me might not be the same person
that moves you and yet we've kind of
created this shell of an experience it's
almost like a mad lib right where they
learn sort of this this outline this
technique and then they can take it and
fill in their own content and aside from
the the simon Sinek book that you
mentioned which I do recommend people
check out it does come pop up a lot on
the podcast are there any other books
that either you've recommended to
managers or employees or that you've
just recommended or gifted to other
people well I definitely give people a
lot of people that Helen in Harville
book that I was talking about getting
the love you want something else that we
did a lot of reading at soul cycle is
setting the table by Danny Meyer just
for um you know we we also ran
incredibly interesting hospitality
school for people that worked in the
front of house and not in those rooms
you know we were all big fans of the
Tony Hsieh book delivering happiness and
I think those were like some of our
favorites yeah Danny Meyer is amazing
very very fascinating guy for people who
don't recognize the name you should look
it up how are we doing on time I do not
have a countdown I just I do I've done
what was that 7:35 okay great let's see
I would love to hear what you are
currently most excited about and why
because much like my question at the
very beginning about what you saw on
that bartender and how you kind of pick
where you're going to allocate your time
you you've made some very deliberate
choices and when you make a choice when
you make a decision right your
cutting yourself off just like incision
you're cutting yourself off from other
possibilities there's an opportunity
cost so what are you most excited about
now professionally personally or
anything in between um it's funny to
talk about opportunity cost because for
the longest time I really thought you
could just do everything and I'm
starting to I'm starting to understand
that there are only a certain amount of
hours in the day but I will say that you
know while sitting here in the middle of
made by we it's really interesting
because I think that it's definitely a
good example of something that I am
thinking a lot about these days which is
you know how how are people connecting
in a world where people spend most of
their time on their phones or connecting
digitally I think that's something
that's really interesting to think about
is you know where are the places and
what are the experiences that we're
delivering to people to allow them to
connect you know we're reading about
loneliness as an epidemic
you know I'm personally terrified
watching my 13 year old and the way she
interacts with her friends and their
phones you know they're all in the same
room and yet they're all on their phones
communicating and so I am really
obsessed with the fact that people are
lonely and people are unhappy and how
are we giving people skills to be
happier and how are we giving them
places to find those connections and so
you know a place like this when I think
about it it's really a new version of a
community center you know a place where
we can go and especially in an economy
where so many of us are now have the
luxury of you know having our own
company working by herself in our
apartment you know that all sounds great
until the day that you wake up and think
I could really use somebody else around
me to help me get inspired and so really
thinking about you know how people
connect and and what kind of tools we
need to give them so that they can
connect and connect in meaningful ways
this is a beautiful space I mean I don't
know how people in the audience feel but
it's it's my first time here and I would
love I could have used a place like this
many years ago
and hopefully there'll be many many more
come anytime yeah it's absolutely
absolutely stunning and let's let's wrap
up with just a few final questions and
this one sometimes a good question
sometimes a terrible question we'll find
out and that is if you could put a
message question a quote anything at all
and metaphorically speaking on a
billboard to get some a message out to
millions or billions of people
non-commercial for the time being
do you have any thoughts on what you
might put on that for me this is very
easy one you know I'm a terrible
claustrophobic I did not know that yes I
am a terrible claustrophobic and ready
for this I live in New York City I do
not take elevators like do not never
don't take elevators have gone to
weddings black-tie weddings at the
Rainbow Room 71 flights I walk yeah Wow
so it's presumably you're not in like a
you know running shoes when you go to
such a function I have a whole situation
I have my heels in a bag and I wear my
sneakers up in full hair makeup outfit I
make it to the top I blot I put my heels
on and I walk out like nothing happens
[Music]
but yes I elevators are not my thing
and so if I was going to put a billboard
off I think that it would say there is
no elevator to success you have to take
the stairs I love it I dig it and do you
have any final comments asks
recommendations anything at all do you
like to say before we wrap up I don't
think so I'm so happy I got a chance to
talk to you and thank you so much for
coming I know that people are so excited
to have you in the space so it's awesome
to have you here oh it's great to be
here and it's nice to see you again
I meant for people who don't know we've
spent time together before and I've been
looking forward to this and as soon as
we had a chance the very first time to
spend you know 10 or 15 minutes ago I
was like I need to get her on the
cast at some point in my head so here we
are and it's been really fun I've taken
so many notes everybody in craps watch
me taking all these notes for things
that I'm gonna follow up on and and dig
into where are the best places for
people to find you learn more about what
you're up to
we work anything that you'd like to
mention interpretive resources and of
course I'll put these in the show notes
online as well so you can always find
out what's going on in this space on our
Instagram is that right jewel where are
you what's the best way to find out
about stuff in this space yes made dot
by dot we it's very hard to get domain
all right there we go and a good way to
find out what's going on with me is
either at my Instagram which is at Julie
rice underscore or Elizabeth and I have
a great Instagram which is at Sol
founders awesome thank you so much for
taking the time this is really been fun
thank you everybody for coming and until
next time see you around hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email for me would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday event provides a little morsel of
fun for the
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy
[Applause]
you